All of us routinely use file systems. Quite often, not the one that is
on our local machine, be it a desktop or laptop, but one that is on a local area
network, connecting us to a workplace or university.
NFS, which stands for Network File System. And
just like the word xerox is used often as a verb, to denote copying, NFS has
become a generic name to signify any file
system that we access remotely. So here is
a trivia quiz for you. NFS is a name given to the first network file system that
was ever built. In this question I want you to name the company and the year
that NFS was first built. And the company
choices for you are all familiar names: IBM, Sun
Microsystems, HP, Apple, Microsoft, and
Google. And here are the choices of years for you 1975, 85, 95, 2005.